at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
pornhub
just kidding this episode is brought to
you by four sigmatic
which is part of my morning routine also
part of my afternoon
routine routine saves me so there are
a number of ways that i use for sigmatic
in the mornings
i regularly start with their mushroom
coffee instead of regular coffee
and it doesn't taste like mushroom let
me explain this first of all
zero sugar zero calories half the
caffeine of regular coffee
it's easy on my stomach tastes amazing
and all you have to do
is add hot water i use travel packets
i've been to probably a dozen countries
with various products from four sigmatic
and their mushroom coffee is top of the
list
that's number one i travel with it i
recommend it i give it to my employees
i give it to house guests so if you're
one of the sixty percent of americans or
more who drink coffee daily
consider switching it up this stuff is
amazing that's part one
that is the cognitive enhancement side
easy on the system side energizing side
the next is actually their chaga tea
which tastes delicious it is
decaf completely decaf and some may
recognize chaga it is nicknamed the king
of the mushrooms
it is excellent for immune system
support
so needless to say i am focused on that
right now
myself and so i will often have that in
the afternoons they make all sorts of
different mushroom blends
if you are doing exercise as i am on a
daily basis to keep myself sane
cordyceps excellent for endurance they
have a whole slew of options that you
can check out
every single batch is third party lab
tested for heavy metals allergens all
the bad stuff
to make sure that what gets into your
hands is what you want to put in your
mouth and they always offer a 100
money back guarantee so you can try it
risk free why not
i've worked out an exclusive offer with
four sigmatic on their best-selling
lion's mane coffee i literally have a
mug full of it in front of me right now
and this is just for you my dear podcast
listeners receive up to 39
off i don't know how we arrived at 39
but 39
off it's a lot they're best-selling
lions main coffee bundles to claim this
deal you must go to 4sigmatic.com
tim this offer is only for you and is
not available on
their regular website go to four
sigmatic that's f
f-o-u-r-s-i-g-m-a-t-i-c
dot com slash tim to get yourself some
awesome and delicious mushroom
coffee full discount is applied at
checkout
this episode is brought to you by
element spelled lmnt
what on earth is element it is a
delicious sugar-free
electrolyte drink mix i've stocked up on
boxes and boxes of this it was one of
the first things that i bought
when i saw covid coming down the pike
and i usually use one to two per day
element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto
low carb or paleo diet or if you drink a
ton of water and you might not
have the right balance that's often when
i drink it or if you're doing any type
of endurance exercise
mountain biking etc another application
if you've ever struggled to feel good
on keto low carb or paleo it's most
likely because even if you're
consciously consuming electrolytes
you're just not getting enough and it
relates to a bunch of stuff like a
hormone called aldosterone blah blah
blah when insulin is low but suffice to
say
this is where element again spelled lmnt
can help my favorite flavor by far is
citrus salt
which is a side note you can also use to
make a kick-ass
no-sugar margarita but for special
occasions obviously
you're probably already familiar with
one of the names behind it
rob wolf r-o-b-b rob wolf who is a
former
research biochemist and two-time new
york times best-selling author of the
paleo solution and wired to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch
that's how it got started his brazilian
jiu jitsu coaches turned him onto
electrolytes
as a performance enhancer things clicked
and bam
company was born so if you're on a low
carb diet or
fasting electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness
and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be
by one of my favorite athlete friends
three navy seal teams as prescribed by
their master chief marine units fbi
sniper teams at least
five nfl teams who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on and on
you can try it risk free if you don't
like it
element will give you your money back no
questions asked they have extremely low
return rates so again element lmnt came
up with a
very special offer for you guys they've
created tim's club
just go to drinkelement.com
tim select subscribe and save and use
promo code tim's club
to get the 30 count box of element for
only 36 dollars
this will be valid for the lifetime of
the subscription and you can pause at
any time
so again check it out it's drink
lmnt.com
tim for this exclusive offer using promo
code tim's club one more time
drink lmnt element so drink
lmnt.com tim and promo code tim's club
check it out
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to interview
world class performers from all
different disciplines and
my guest today is mike novogratz michael
novogratz
at novogratz that's n-o-v-o-g-r-a-t-z
on twitter is the founder and ceo of
galaxy digital
galaxy digital dot io he was formerly a
partner and president of fortress
investment group llc
prior to fortress mr novogratz spent 11
years at goldman sachs where he was
elected partner in 1998.
mr novogratz served on the new york
federal reserve's investment advisory
committee on financial markets from 2012
to 2015.
mike also serves as the chairman of the
bail project and has made criminal
justice reform a focus of his family's
foundation
he serves as the chairman of hudson
river park friends and sits on the
boards of
nyu langone from getting that correct
medical center and
princeton varsity club jazz foundation
of america
and artists for peace and justice mr
novogratz received an abn economics from
princeton university
and served as a helicopter pilot in the
u.s army
mike welcome to the show thanks a lot
tim
and this has been a long time coming i'm
excited to have you on the show
you have so many stories you have an
unvarnished personality and
uh you have just a such a medley of
experience
that i'm glad that we were finally able
to
get on the phone to record this for
public consumption so thanks for making
the time
no i'm excited i sometimes feel like we
were separated at birth me and you
yeah we got yeah we have long island we
have princeton we have
wrestling uh as you put it a little bit
crazy uh
psychedelics meditation crypto the list
is long and i thought we could start
with a place that might seem like a
total non-sequitur but i have to ask
i was in preparation for this
conversation reading a
a really nicely done profile in the new
yorker
written by gary steingart and there is a
there's a phrase that came up multiple
times that i have to ask you about which
was
speed racer pants he kept on mentioning
you're wearing sp
speed racer pants what are what are
these pants i have a pair of white pants
with a big rage stripe on the side of
them
and they look like the pants speed racer
used to wear
i bought them in la at fred siegel one
day when i was just bored and
uh i started wearing them around and no
one in new york was wearing straight
pants and so
it was quite the thing for us for about
a year
and you seem to to have a fair amount of
lore
surrounding you which certainly became
even more clear as i was doing homework
for this conversation
and one of them is piloting a helicopter
down prospect avenue
now i'd like to know if that's true and
uh
either way maybe you could explain what
prospect avenue is but did that actually
happen
you know unfortunately it did happen uh
i've had a tendency to drink too much at
big parties and you know princeton has
this
reunion celebration every year where all
the classes come by and
and uh after the p-rate this is a parade
of
you know hundreds and hundreds of people
starting with the oldest graduate who
you know is often 103 years old all the
way to the new grads
everyone migrates to this prospect
avenue and one year i had to leave early
uh for an event and i was like okay just
i'll
i'll show off to my friends a little bit
and so i got a helicopter i was gonna
take me back to new york city and i
asked the pilot if i could drive and
we just buzzed the buzz prospect street
uh
much to the thrill of my friends and
probably the dismay of everyone else
[Laughter]
what was your princeton experience like
i we're gonna
zoom backwards in time to childhood in
just a little bit but
what was your experience like at
princeton you know i was
a middle-class kid so i showed up a
little intimidated
and you know i thought i was smart in
high school and i showed up at princeton
i think gosh i'm not that smart
uh i thought i was a great wrestler in
high school and i went to princeton i
got my butt whooped and i was like i'm
not that good of a wrestler and so
you know it started off uh intimidated
uh in lots of ways and you know i look
back i took
easier classes than certainly my kids
take
thinking how do i get through this place
and survive it
and you know athletically that flipped
my junior year
uh socially it flipped early and that
was probably the biggest positive
academically it never really flipped i
never really felt
maybe until i did my thesis like i was
really a good enough student
didn't really feel smart enough to
actually join the army and
on a test with 700 other guys got first
place and i was like dude
i'm actually pretty smart i learned
something but i was intimidated most of
princeton
it was interesting that the the positive
side was
socially i was adept and realized you
know i had
my first roommate actually was uh gloria
vanderbilt's on carter cooper who
unfortunately tragically uh you know
committed suicide years later but uh
he was kind of aristocracy right not
just a wealthy new yorker but the you
know the vanderbilts
uh for aristocracy and i went to new
york and
you know i realized he had his own
insecurities as well and he had nice
friends and
other than them teasing me about having
my hair parted in the middle which i
thought was a very cool look back then
but not in new york city
you know i quickly realized that rich
guys middle class guys
they all use the same toilet to [ __ ] and
uh
and that part i think gave me a lot of
confidence in life
that i could compete in essence now this
point we were competing mostly for girls
but i could compete with with anybody
and that sounds like a small little win
but it was actually
when i look back you know where a lot of
kind of confidence started
and you mentioned athletics what flipped
junior year
if i'm remembering correctly for you in
athletics
you know i don't think i reached puberty
until i was about 20.
you know i i was a decent wrestler and i
worked pretty hard at it
and i just got good enough to make
the varsity uh so my first two years i
was really on the junior varsity
uh there was one guy that was better
than me at the same weight and
and he actually took a year off and so
it opened the spot up for me and having
that opportunity to wrestle
you know i just started doing better and
better and i made the
you know the eastern tournament that i
made the national tournament and back
then making the nationals was a huge
check plus for you you felt like you
know you're a real guy in the wrestling
community
and so i came back senior year ready to
you know ready to be an all-american
so it was a whole shift of you know my
my confidence level again
but also i got stronger you know
nowadays kids red shirt they take a year
off
i really wish i i was just getting
strong and
just getting good my senior year i kind
of always needed one more year
it's probably why i've stayed involved
with wrestling my whole life
what did wrestling give you that's a
leading question i
i should probably just ask what impact
it had on you but
having wrestled myself uh you wrestled
longer than i did
but uh i'd love to hear in your words
what part wrestling has played in your
life
if aside from the involvement that you
had later with
beat the streets and and and the the
olympics and so on yeah listen i think
it's a sport that almost like no other
sport
beats the hell out of you i mean it is
so tough from cutting weight
uh to going out on the map by yourself
and just getting crushed
and so you learn to pick yourself up
after you get crushed and you're like
okay
i gotta crush that match i don't need to
get across the next match and i gotta
work a little harder and so
it's resilience if anything the the
train it builds in people is grit
or resilience um when i started beat the
streets we looked a lot at wrestling and
and it's interesting 14 of the 44
presidents the united states had
wrestling in their background
there's no other sport there's no other
sport with that many maybe lincoln used
to go from town to town to wrestle for
money
uh teddy roosevelt was a wrestler uh
and often that toughness and grit ends
up in leadership and so you see a lot of
wrestlers that
move on in life into leadership
positions so let's talk about the
resilience
because when i polled a number of my
friends and
asked them what they would most like me
to discuss with you
it came back to resilience in some form
or another
and in the new yorker piece
there's there's one line which uh we
could also
dissect if we wanted but it says you
know princeton like wall street where
novogratz has made at least three
fortunes and lost at least two is full
of stories about him
so you have this incredibly
powerful and public heroes journey that
you've traveled
more than once and i want to read from a
speech this is the commencement speech
in iowa i don't even know the story of
how this came to be but
we can get to that so as it relates to
grit so you say as i've gotten older
this is in the middle of
the commencement speech as i've gotten
older i've realized that we have two
missions on this earth
to know thyself or as my wife would say
to sort our [ __ ] out
and to walk each other home most people
i've met don't start this journey until
they've really screwed up they've lost a
job
ruined a marriage abused drugs or
alcohol destroyed friendships or just
can't get out of bed i started my
journey at 33 when i had done most of
the above
i was a rising star goldman sachs i was
a partner a president a respected man in
the wall street community
and then i wasn't right after i resigned
from goldman i literally thought my life
was over
i had ruined it okay so
this is winding its way to a question so
that's a little bit of back
story for people who don't have
familiarity and
the question is when that happened
when you have what you might consider a
public
experience like that how do you work
your way through it like psychologically
and emotionally what do you tell
yourself what helps i i'm very curious
to know how you dust yourself off
and what you did that that helped after
something you know
that was my kind of first public
humiliation
failure um you know personal failure
you know fail the people i worked with
and
it was painful i i there's no two ways
around it
you know it was helpful that i had a
supportive family that were just letting
me be
i went into depression uh and
it took a while to kind of work out i
was
i had this narrative that i i'd ruined
my life and i would never get it back
and
i remember you know there was lots of
little pieces of advice first i had one
lawyer
i was so worried what everyone thought
about me and this lawyer said dude
do me a favor write down on a piece of
paper
the people that you think will be at
your funeral when you die at 80.
worry about what those people think all
those other people they don't really
think about you that much
you know and that was kind of liberating
because you as a partner at goldman
sachs
every partner that had left goldman
sachs when you left you got this
beautiful little memo about all you had
done and
you know it was a it was a goal was a
bit of a cult and there was a very
nice way they exited partners and i just
disappeared
you know i was not spoken about i was
like so i kept worrying that i was going
to run into my
ex partners on the street and be be so
embarrassed and so first he helped me
get over that
just think about it but in the long run
i end up
going up to rehab uh in arizona
and you know that was a i kind of got
snickered in a little bit i had this
therapist i never had a therapist before
and he said dude you talk so much
you got to go somewhere where you can
tell your stories and have a safe space
and
there's this beautiful holistic place in
the middle of phoenix
our tucson uh called sierra tucson
and it looked i looked on the pamphlets
it looked so nice and so i went out
there
and you know on day one and i hadn't had
a drink or a drug or got any trouble for
three four five months at the time
but so i flew out there and you check
yourself into a mental health
facility and you're like what the f just
went on here uh and my first roommate
was
in the throes of trying to kick heroin
and he was
not having a good time of it and i'm
like how in god's name did i end up at
this place
but it was probably my first experience
with really digging in and
trying to sort out like what are the
patterns of my life that led to this and
it was kind of
traumatic in that you know the thesis
that
a lot of rehab centers use and addiction
specialists use is that
there are these deep emotional scars
either big t traumas or little t traumas
that
people have a hard time dealing with and
they start using some substance
it might be sex or alcohol or drugs or
control of your food
to medicate those feelings and that
medication
all of a sudden and as you end up doing
more stupid things and you need more of
the medication
and it's this cycle of uh and so that if
you could get to those core issues
it would really help in your journey and
you know you're sitting around a circle
with people and you know one guy's
father kicked him in the spleen he'd
lost his spleen when he's 12 and
almost all the women that were bulimic
or anorexic had suffered incest
and i'm thinking here i had nice parrots
like what
you know i had a pretty nice and it was
traumatizing not
having the big trauma and you know one
of my insights
was sometimes the little trauma 10 years
20 years 30 years later
can have just as much psychological
duress
as big trauma you know and so one man's
pain is no different 10 years later
uh it's just pain uh or fear or
and and so starting the search to find
that out was
unbelievably helpful it also really
started building an underdeveloped
empathy muscle
you know i remember i met one woman who
had been the teacher of the year in
florida for like
nine straight years and she had
she was probably 45 years old and had a
uh
had a relationship maybe 30 40 years old
had a relationship with a
senior and it wasn't even sexual but it
was
close to sexual got caught and next
thing you know she was the pariah of the
town and
got thrown out of teaching and everyone
wanted to shoot her
and as you mentioned was one of the
nicest women i had met
and she had a story she had been abused
by her both father and then stepfather
and had developed a relationship
addiction which
unfortunately then had her having a
relationship with a senior in her school
but instead of being angry wanted a
lyncher you wanted a
hugger and so that that process of
trying to to understand where where
people's
mistakes came from allowed me to start
kind of forgiving
myself a little bit and then since i
didn't really
get to that holistic place
i realized that maybe this is the trick
of how to get started again
i just needed to create a new narrative
and some of the narrative was
i [ __ ] up i went to try to understand
how i [ __ ] up
i haven't solved it all but i'm i'm
starting over
and you know it wasn't until 9 11
happened i uh
i was trying to figure out what to do
and when 9 11 happened uh
my brother called me and
he was in one of the uh big buildings
right next to the twin towers
and he's like dude a plane just hit what
am i supposed to do
and i was like by euro dollars and he
was like what the [ __ ] you talking about
i was like buy
short dated treasury contracts and i was
like and i was like oh no
get out of the building uh and
and i i was like okay brains kind of
screwed up
and then i was with my young son who was
like two at the time
and i was uh
looking on the tv and i was like we
gotta go help so i go wanting to run
down towards the
trade center to see what was going on
and he started crying and i was like
okay that's not helping
so we ran back and watched it on tv but
i
you know my army side of me wanted to
participate and they there was no real
room for volunteers and i felt like i
got to go do something
and i realized i hadn't fulfilled kind
of my
my wall street journey and so i
literally it was a 911
insight and i you know went back to work
at fortress and
and luckily you know had a lot of good
luck and good great partners
you know five or six years later we not
even six years later we rang the bell at
the stock market and
you know we were all billionaires and it
was just kind of heady
experience because the journey from you
know walking out of goldman sachs and
having one of the senior partners say
well you know maybe you'll work against
some time
you know i'm thinking to myself jesus
wasn't that bad
uh but really feeling like you might
never work again until six years later
you know feel like you're on top of the
world you know it was kind of a heady
ride
what did your self-care program if it
existed
look like between rehab and ringing the
bell
did anything change noticeably any type
of habits or routines or anything that
helped during that period
so i gave up drinking for
13 months and you know i have been a
man who loves parties who loves drinking
who's who doesn't drink at home but a
very social drinker my whole life
and that was difficult because trying to
be able to be social
not with a glass of wine or a beer or
jack daniels in my hand was tough
and i gave up recreational drugs and you
know
14 months later i did something which i
think was important i ran this thing
called the marathon of the sands
which was six marathons in a row across
the sahara
it was one of the original adventure
races
700 people from 100 countries and you
literally
run across the damn desert and it would
get to 130 degrees during the day and
freeze at night
and about halfway into it i was like ah
it's good to be alive and it just felt
like what the f are you complaining
about you're alive
at this beautiful settings and you're
meeting new people and
that was really the big trigger and so
staying fit you know at that age i ran a
lot
but it was that push yourself into the
uncomfort zone physically even
and realize you're still alive dude
you're not dead and so that's
that was right before you know the 9 11
have that was whatever the
june before september but that was
really the turning point now they asked
the question
where i felt like okay i can go back to
work and then at fortress
you know there was a lot of stress at
work because i felt
like you know even though i thought i
made some big breakthroughs there were
parts of my story i hadn't sorted out
one is why i carried all this pressure
all the time
you know that stopped it from being
joyful and so i
you know exercise i still i wasn't
really into meditation
until probably 2006 2007
you know so early on it was just
exercise my core issues
were pressure i when i made partner at
goldman sachs i felt relieved
i remember lloyd blankfein called me up
he said don't tell my wife it's one of
the most joyful days of my life even
more than my
wedding and i'm thinking to myself i
think that
i should have said that boy's going to
come get yell at me i
didn't feel that i felt relieved like ah
i think i checked that box and i was
thinking back on it i was like well
that's kind of shitty that he felt that
much pressure to be a partner goldman
sachs well the hell really cared
you know i lost most of the big
wrestling matches in my life because i
felt so much pressure
to win that when i knew it was an
important match i wouldn't wrestle as
well
and so i got a lot of second places and
i would remember walking out of the mat
feeling exhausted beforehand
and it took me a while matter of fact i
remember the moment
where i had my first insight i had
the year before i had been at this
investor conference called lyford key
and byron wien used to run it he was a
legend from morgan stanley
and this was the first legendary
investor conference you had to be a
legend to be there and you had to share
ideas
and i got invited in 2006 probably
maybe 2005 and it was such an honor to
be there
i was one of the young guys and you had
to give your three
stories stocks or ideas and uh
it came to me and the guy before me had
used one of mine and i just panicked and
i literally was like uh
uh uh and i'm sweating and it was one of
the most miserable
five minutes of my life so much so the
guy next to me was like
dude that wasn't that bad but i've got a
plane leaving soon if you want to go
and i remember feeling all this stress
about and i was telling my wife i was
like i don't
this is so much stress i'm not having
fun i should just
do something else in my life and she was
like uh dude you hired all these people
uh you just hired one of your best
friends you left his firm to work for
you like like
sort it out and you know has luck would
happen i
i have this life where i've stolen
mentorship
or found it or you know been gifted at
you know
in strange places and i was one of my
investors suggested i have lunch with
barack who had been the prime minister
of israel and uh
one of their great generals one of the
and he allegedly had the highest iq in
the israeli army
and i was sitting with him and he was a
charming charming guy
later became a friend and he looked at
me he said no regrets
i think i figured you out you know
you're not very smart i was like thank
you he said but you're lucky
you're lucky and then he said don't
worry about it you know louis bacon
who is one of the macro legends you know
one of the best investors of all time
and bruce covener uh they're they remind
me a little they they think they're
smart but they're mostly lucky
and i'm looking at them and then he gave
me a quote in french of course i don't
speak french and
i was like translate you know i'm not so
smart and it was from nepali and i don't
hire smart generals i had lucky generals
and it was a and it was about intuition
and
that his napoleon's thought was
these generals know where to be on the
battlefield right then they can
pattern recognize the thing they have a
certain intuition
and we don't have a word for it
therefore we call it luck and
the moment he said that the way my brain
functioned as an investor the way i
operated in life it clicked i was like
that's what i do
i have pat like i'm actually and
i realized i didn't need once i knew
what i needed to make investments to
make decisions
i didn't need to fulfill what you think
i needed
right i remember being so worried when i
was at life for key that someone was
going to ask me
who the finance minister of russia was
because i was telling him i owned all
these russian rubles and i forgot the
guy's name
but i didn't really need to know the
guy's name for my investment confidence
other people might and that was
liberating
and from the moment that happened i
could tell the story of how i made
investment decisions
and has so much more confidence i had my
hedge fund went from 300 million to 2
billion in six months
the returns went up but most importantly
the joy showed up
uh it was more fun and the confidence
came i was like i know i can always
if i need to sit in front of the screen
and sort out markets and make money from
them
and so you know one of the great
breakthroughs literally was was from
this guy
who you know was a famous jewish general
israeli general and uh i don't know how
i seem to have
gotten sidetracked from your question
but oh no this show is all about side
tracks those are usually really the
interesting alleys have all sorts of
tidbits so let's dig into
intuition because this seems to show up
again
again
and again in your life and i'd be very
curious to know let's just say in that
six month period
where you go vertical basically in
assets under management
how have you learned if you have to
discern
intuition and pattern recognition
from say overconfidence right or
rational confidence
in a position or a trait or something
like that how have you learned to wield
and discern what is what yeah it's a
great question
and listen the world the world's best
speculators or macro traders have two
things in common
they have this pattern recognition
intuition
i put that in one bucket and then i have
discipline
and i sent the three things and then
they have an unbelievable competitive
spirit
and you know i look at guys like stan
druckenmiller and paul jones and louis
bacon
and to be honest they're just they've
done better than i have uh
and it wasn't because because i spoke to
them enough to understand
of their understanding of markets or
intuition uh
their discipline was just
better and it was and i was like why are
they so much more disciplined than i
i think partly they're just more
disciplined than i but they're more
competitive they just
cared more it was interesting i couldn't
tell if that was in life a strength or a
weakness
but there you watched that michael
jordan documentary
and the one thing that every single
person who watches it comes out is
he cared so he was the most competitive
man i think i've ever seen in anything
michael jordan
you know the great speculators are very
competitive like that and
and shockingly i'm just not as
competitive uh and listen i've done spec
i've done
very well by almost any standard but not
in the legend standard
uh that you know i know who the legends
are because i've been around them
and so i think about that a lot and i'm
trying to figure out you know that
that's not all terrible like you'd like
some more discipline
and i think it has allowed me to have a
more diverse life
than some of my peers but i think about
that but that's how you
the only way you end up trusting your
intuition
to get to your question is to have some
set of rules that you
manage your risk by your life by your
because you're
you're still anxious right we're
learning to trust ourselves
so i think i'm right right it's this
business that i think
not that i know you really think like
this
lines up i'm almost positive bitcoin is
going to go up right now
but if it doesn't you've got to have
some circuit breaker
that says you know i could have been
wrong you know
no one's right 100 of the time right no
one's right 80
of the time in markets and so you need a
circuit breaker and so that's a series
of rules that you
manage your portfolio by manage your
life by lots of ways and that's where
discipline really helps and that's where
i've
often let myself down a little bit and
that's sometimes
just trying to do too many things
sometimes you know
just not being tough enough on myself
but
that's the challenge of anyone who goes
into my business it's those
it's really hard to learn that you're
actually good at it
because you know it's it's not a skill
that
you know how do you say i've got good
intuition right it takes a long time for
you to trust yourself
and then how do you hold steady to
really having your portfolio constantly
being
a collection of your guesses it sounds
like it should be a tautology right
i'm bullish therefore i'm long but i
would tell you that
19 out of 20 people that try to be
traders
that sentence isn't consistent with them
ninety percent of the time
could you elaborate on that yeah yeah so
someone is bullish they say i think the
stock market's going up but i'm not
going to buy it yet
right i think the stock market's going
up but i'm going to buy a little bit but
i'm going to sell calls on it
so that it goes up they barely make any
money uh
stan druckenmatter when he's you hear
him on tv if he says i think the
market's going up you can
better believe he's long yeah and just
for people who
are are not in uh in the investing world
so long meaning he is
i suppose in the simplest iteration
buying things with the expectation they
will appreciate their
value yeah apologies i i forget
the audience
and so that's the battle of
of being a speculator but that
translates into the battle of life and
you know listen even
i guess if you're investing in movies
you have some algorithm in your head
or a written algorithm of what you think
makes for a good bet
and so you invest you invest you invest
at one point
right your track record your wins versus
losses are going to tell you are you
good at this
but really taking the time to understand
what that algorithm is
like how do you make decisions in
investing in movies or investing in
small businesses right if you're a
venture capitalist or investing in
markets and so one of my insights was
always like
any one of those processes you take in
information
you process it through an algorithm and
you have to then manage it
like manage the risk of it somehow and
so that i use that process
in lots of things but some you know and
not every job
certainly not every investing job is
based on intuition quite frankly very
few are
because the the more intuition
based the investing is the more anxiety
there is
right if you're an arbitrager you buy
something for
you know eight dollars uh on one market
and sell it for 10 on another
there's not a whole lot of risk and so
that is just being commercial
and so i always tell people that you got
to try to understand yourself and figure
out where your dna where your
personality type fits into the space
let's come back to one of the names you
mentioned and that's
paul jones or paul tudor jones who has
hit the news quite widely in the last
few weeks because of his
extensive discussion of bitcoin
specifically in one of his memos i'm not
sure if he refers to them as memos
or letters or something else but
nonetheless this has made the round
that paul tudor jones has de-risked
bitcoin for institutional investors here
comes wall street etc
you've referred to yourself as the force
gump of bitcoin
so so i'll give you two questions and
you can choose which one you want to
tackle first so
one is why are you the forest gump
bitcoin and then the second is
how are you different from paul tudor
jones like how do you guys i know you
know
each other quite well how are you most
different or most similar so that's a
great question
so the forrest gump of bitcoin was kind
of a shtick i was with the first
institutional grade investor that
started talking about it
you know for better or worse you know
back in when it was trading around 100 i
was on
and it was i i promised my partners
quite frankly
that we wouldn't talk about crypto
because fortress was a real asset
company and we weren't going to talk
about these digital assets
and i was at some conference i didn't
know the press was there i made some
witty comments about bitcoin
and the next day i was on the cover of
the financial times um
and then i got sucked into bitcoin
because everyone would call me and ask
me what i thought
and at that point i didn't really
understand how it worked that much i
understood
that it was a thing that was going to go
higher but
partly by being forced to publicly speak
about it you know i
got asked to speak at the oxford union
and
i really had to study and you know
try to understand how the damn thing
worked and so i became kind of an
unofficial
spokesperson or one of the unofficial
spokesperson for it
paul and i are as close in terms of what
we have done
we ran similar businesses his was bigger
and a little bit better
he's been a role model in philanthropy
in spirit
uh like if i had an older brother 10
years were different you know
that my parents didn't tell me about it
would be paul and so
it's fun to see him getting involved in
bitcoin uh for me personally
uh it's important because you know i
said i was pretty damn good
but paul is one of those legends you
know they're
literally honestly three or four guys of
his stature in the whole macro space in
the last 30 years
and so for him to get involved it
basically says this is
this is a real macro instrument you know
there's no more debate on
his bitcoin it might not always go up it
might go up and down
you might not put it in your portfolio
but there's no shame in in being
involved with
the space anymore and that's a big deal
because
for stores of value and bitcoin is
really becoming a store of value
they only become stores of value when
people believe they are
and so it's a belief system bitcoin is
is not just the code it's really the
social construct
i say it's this you say it's says
therefore it is this
and so we already have jack dorsey whose
twitter handle says bitcoin
and abby johnson from fidelity and pete
brigger from fortress that
all bought it personally or had their
businesses involved with it
wences casa race and mickey melker i
mean these are kind of legends in their
space
paul's the first kind of legend in the
hedge fund space that didn't just buy it
personally but he bought it in his fund
and so it opens up a whole new avenue of
potential
participants in that community which i
think is really really significant
if we had to put on the the hat of
forecaster or nostradamus
what do you predict if you're
comfortable going for it with
bitcoin cryptocurrency etc in the next
let's just call it 12 months
it's currently may 18th when we record
this
2020. mark it down and write it down uh
we're trading roughly 9 600 dollars per
bitcoin
right now i think we'll take out 10 000
soon and end the year closer to 20 000
the old highs
once these store values start building
momentum
uh there's not a lot of supply we've had
this thing called the happening where
there's half the supply being mined
than there was even a week ago but
mostly
the story is finally catching broader
uh adoption and it's not just hedge
funds they're gonna be able to buy it
you're gonna see wealth managers start
selling it to their clients through
products we have a
bitcoin fund that's targeted to the 50
to 80 year olds
in america that buy there that make
their investment decisions through
td ameritrade or charles schwab or
goldman sachs
are registered investment advisors
right bitcoin has been a young man's
game it's been
gen z and the millennials it's been
bought on coinbase app or square
or robin hood those things aren't going
away quite frankly there could be more
of them
right facebook's calibra is going to
allow you to buy bitcoin and that'll be
2
000 3 000 people using that wallet and
so there are so many more
avenues of access i always tell people
if it was easy to buy the price would be
far higher already right bitcoin's been
hard to buy
and a year from now it's going to be
that much easier
so thank you i'm really bullish and i
you know listen i don't have
uh i'm always careful when i'm when i
say really because
you know these things are recorded and
you come back later and people are going
damn that guy was stupid if
it doesn't work uh and so you're
cautious to be that bullish
publicly but i haven't seen things line
up as well
uh in a long time let's rewind the clock
as promised
uh it feels like probably an hour
or so ago maybe maybe a little bit less
to
family and i know this is a little bit
like memento as in how non-linear
this is but you grew up in a big family
it seems like
with with no shortage of strong
personalities
could you describe for folks what
your family was like what your childhood
was like
growing up sure so for people of my age
uh that used to watch john news movies
like pretty in pink and 16 candles
that was pretty much the neighborhood i
grew up in like we were straight up the
middle
suburban middle class all-american
family my dad was an army officer
uh so he was a major he went to vietnam
twice when i was very young
a major than a lieutenant colonel for
like my my growing up years
uh i went to a public high school we had
you know seven of us
uh seven of us in a house that had one
and a half well two bathrooms one for my
parents and one for the rest of us
and you know we fought over the brush
and the blow dryer because back then you
blew dry your hair if you were a cool
dude um my mother
uh didn't go to college she got married
when she was 18 to my dad
they just had their 60th anniversary or
19. she got married
60th anniversary and she was beautiful
and i think she had this fascination
with the kennedys
because she named my sister jackie and
you know
my brother bobby and we've got a john
john and
you know my dad was a handsome football
player a football star at west point
and my mother thought
we should you know we should be them you
know why not us
and so she was the one that kind of
drove the pressure to succeed not in a
really harsh way just in a like you know
we used to complain about kids and she
says well if that girl would jump off a
bridge would you jump off a bridge
the same old saying that most suburban
parents used but there was a pressure my
mom put
of excellence that we could rise and in
the background my father had been the
lineman of the year in college football
he never has once mentioned a thing he
would he's the least
braggadocio guy very humble but he
didn't have to
say much because he had my mom would say
it all for him but we had this sense of
excellence from my dad
that he had been this star football
player we also had a sense of service
you know my mom used to always say
ah you're given so much you know you got
to give back and i look back i'm like we
had seven kids fighting over one brush
but you know we were you know it was a
catholic family there was lots of love
involved we might we come from a big
extended family as well and so
we felt special you know it was special
to be an overgratz and my mother made it
special to be an overgratz
uh and so we ran for office at the
student elections and
you know didn't always win actually i
lost most of the time but
but like even the confidence to be the
third grader running for class president
came from i think parents that made you
feel especially
my dad was tough like it was not he was
a military guy and he grew up in a
austrian immigrant family and so we got
whacked around a lot my brother and i
uh we always complained that by the time
my little brothers and sisters who were
there was a seven year gap between the
top three and the bottom four came
around
my parents were soft
[Laughter]
but you know i look about this big
family all the time and i
the the one thing that i'm sure that
came out of it was
you're willing to take more risk in life
when you know if you screw up
there's people that are going to catch
you uh there's
brothers and sisters that'll love you
anyway uh
and they also on the flip side when
you're doing really well
they don't buy that schtick either you
know they're appreciative of it they
they applaud but you're not more special
uh just because you made a bunch of
money or got this award or
uh and so it's humbling
it's it's safety on the downside and
it's humbling on the upside um
and so that's listen we've all drafted
off of each other
you know i always laugh that's you know
it's a pain in the ass to have such a
famous sister because wherever i go
everyone knows my sister because she's
always trying to
save the world you should say a few
words about that because people may not
recognize jackie equals jacqueline
jacqueline novogratz
just a few words about you can you say a
few words about her my sister's one of
the unique
souls that from like age five
decided she wanted to change the world
and so she was like a brownie then a
girl scout and
she started this organization the acumen
fund which
was really kind of the father of venture
philanthropy or impact investing
uh and has spent her whole life
trying to figure out how to to change
systems how to
invest in the poorest of uh
you know the citizens on this cut the
planet to build
permanent structures around housing and
and
water and education uh and really to
change the conversation to
start with the conversation of dignity
and you know she developed a huge
following in that
development world and in the conference
world uh
she's got you know branches all over the
world now of
young acolytes that want to be like her
and so
you know what's interesting what i
notice about her and i notice about some
other leaders but not many
is that she's never not known true north
like she's and most people and myself
included i
try to be a pretty good guy and i do a
lot of good stuff
but my compass gets out of kilter plenty
of times
gets a kilter from my own desires it
feels pretty good
uh gets out of kilter because i get
excited about
something i lose my own focus you know i
put my
sister in a special bucket you know
brian stevenson is one of my heroes from
the equal justice initiative who's
really one of our
great civil rights leaders and you meet
with him and you're like after just a
few
hours with him you're like he's probably
never
not known true north uh and so
you know that's listen it's inspiring to
be around those people it's sometimes
humbling and frustrating because you're
like uh
but it's it's good to have them around
because it grounds you a little bit
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by magic
spoon a brand new cereal that is low
carb high protein and
zero sugar i just had a bowl of their
cocoa flavor that's my favorite an hour
ago
it tastes just like your favorite cereal
that you remember from childhood
but it's actually good for you each
serving has 11 grams of protein 3 grams
of net carbs
0 grams of sugar and only 110 calories
and their flavors are delicious it comes
in your favorite
traditional cereal flavors you might
remember like cocoa frosted and
blueberry
they also have limited edition flavors
like honey nut and peanut butter my
favorites
are cocoa and peanut butter i'll usually
have them with
really creamy whole milk or some type of
unsweetened
coconut milk something like that another
fun fact one of this podcast's most
popular guests
dr peter attia routinely crushes six to
seven servings at a time
with no glycemic response that means
practically no
blood sugar response which is pretty
miraculous he likes this product so much
that he invested in magic spoon
listeners of this podcast get free
shipping and a 100
happiness guarantee at magicspoon.com
tim
so if you don't love it you get a full
refund no questions asked
again that's magicspoon.com tim and use
code
tim pretty easy to remember
magicspoon.com
and use code tim check it out
see you spoke earlier of feeling immense
pressure say going out on the wrestling
mat
or at the investment conference
coming up to your your five minutes and
so on you have a large family
many high achievers in that family
do you think any part of that comes from
a
pressure or expectation to succeed
that was made explicit or implicitly
clear from your parents and i know
that's
a very binary question but i i'm just
curious yeah i mean it's a big yes and i
don't know if it was
i think it was more implicitly you know
my mother was very good at making us all
feel like we were the special one
and for whatever reason from you know
kindergarten on my teachers treated me
better than everybody else my parents
and so i literally remember if i got
didn't get an a in like first grade
on the way home taking the paper
crumbling up and throating in the sewer
and i'm thinking myself now that i've
had young kids it's incomprehensible for
me to think
that a five or six or seven year old
would throw a paper away if you didn't
get a day
like i would like who thinks like that
so somehow at that very young age
uh i i said in that article with gary
steiner
when i was at rehab i had to complain my
mother because everyone's got to blame
their parents
uh i said you put so much pressure on me
because she used to tell everybody
because i talked all the time that i was
going to be a senator
and my mother very quick on her feet
said yeah
he did all right i should have said he
should have been the president
you know your little kid you pick up
cues that
my parents never meant to put pressure
on their kids i don't think in that kind
of way
but you pick up cues and they become
your operating system
and i operated with that system i still
have a little bit of enemy
for so long a period of time that i
needed to be perfect
so i i remember cheating like i was like
why am i cheating
on a high school test when i was the
smartest guy in the goddamn class
uh because i didn't know the answer and
what i'm not going to get an a
like that pressure was irrational
and of course my my freaking dad never
told a lie in his life he's another
choir boy
they're not going to condone cheating on
a high school test my mother wouldn't
condone it but like
and so it's interesting when i talked
earlier about big t
trauma and little t trauma like the
little t trauma of picking up some story
for me was just as powerful as you know
you know unfortunately for other people
haven't gotten beaten up
and so that i think you know again i
i have a loving mom and dad and
interesting about them is they've gotten
nicer and nicer
with each year so my dad's 83 my mom's
79 and you you literally
it's just fun to see parents grow and
change and
and so i've got nothing but great things
to say but
i do think and i said that in that
speech i wrote that you know everyone's
journey is to kind of figure out their
parental issues
and how their parents impacted them and
then
to understand it to let it go and love
their parents
and you know it took me a long time to
figure out where that pressure came from
and again i don't blame anybody for it
but it certainly was there
so let's let's come back to that speech
because this
might be related what what i'm about to
ask so
you have i would not call it a small
tattoo on your forearm can you descri
can you describe this tattoo for people
please
i do i have i have a forearm length
uh jaguar slash puma i act i call it a
puma but you might think of it as a
jaguar
uh big black puma tattoo that goes from
my
basically the whole length of my right
forearm that i got
literally my brother had given me a
tattoo for christmas a few years earlier
and after uh my first ayahuasca
experience where i
literally on day three transformed into
a puma
i was gonna call it black panther but
the movie had already come out so i was
like i'm a boom i'm not a panther
and growled and crawled around uh
the floor two nights in a row uh and was
so moved by the whole
beauty of that experience i decided i
would get a small tattoo
and i walked into this famous tattoo
parlor called smith street tattoos where
my brother had
you know got me the appointment and set
it up
and i told the guy to get this tattoo
and i was gonna get a small one on my
shoulder
and the guy looked at me and he's like
dude with all respect you're old as [ __ ]
and you're gonna get it to get a tattoo
that people can see
and i was like that was such a genius
like i was like it's a genius it's just
you know when you hear the truth
so i put my forearm down there and i
walked home with this giant eight inch
tattoo of a
of a jaguar puma on my on my right arm
and i love it
i have to say i love it it gives me
power i realize your forearms don't get
flabby it's like the one part of your
body that stays fit
so you mentioned ayahuasca and
this experience minus the puma
in this commencement address why did you
why did you decide to include
that you know it was my first
commencement address and i
worked hard on it and and the thesis was
know thyself and there's so many ways
one can learn about themselves and
and that journey that i went on in
costa rica was unbelievably powerful and
i ended up getting different
things from it that i thought i would um
but afterwards i was trying to convince
my sister and brother-in-law that they
should do this and
i really then started thinking barring
people that have
you know bipolar or mental health issues
would an ayahuasca trip not benefit
someone
as much as it might be tough and scary
like should we put every politician on
the world through that experience before
they're allowed to serve
and i kept coming up with yes and so i
was like
if you're a young college student and
you're
physically okay to do this is there
anything
bad and i couldn't come up with it and
so i thought you know
i'll talk about it publicly and part of
this was in a chapter or a part of the
speech about destigmatizing mental
health
like i think you know one of the
things we need to do as a society is to
allow
that people have mental health issues
that depression is real and
and that you know people have [ __ ] to
work through
and that we should help them work
through that and you know both
psilocybin
uh and ayahuasca are
i just think two things in that toolkit
powerful things in that toolkit of how
one can process trauma one can learn
about themselves one can
dig into the places that they haven't
understood before and
you know it's funny once you see it you
cannot see it yeah that's true
so i have a sister to tell her story but
i will
that went down after i did to the same
same place
and i was laughing about
being a puma and she was like god damn
it next thing you know her
her hands were becoming kind of furry
and like a cat and she hates cats she's
like i hate cats take it cause i can't
really
become a cat and next thing you know she
climbed up this
ladder and she's looking at it and it
brought her back to this
high school i'm not high school i'm
sorry like a little little school uh
theater where she was the cheshire cat
looking out on the audience
and ivory she told me the story i
remembered i was the older brother
sitting there she was probably five or
six at the time
and she was the cutest kid in the plate
of course she was my sister
and after the uh the play i remember
telling
all she stole the show she stole the
show she was so great i mean she
probably had like three lines
but she was the cheshire cat in alice in
wonderland and
for her coming off what she
saw on this ayahuasca trip was all the
other girls being mean to her because
she was getting all the attention
and interestingly enough her whole life
she'd never put her head up again
she always has been unbelievably
supportive of everyone she is literally
our support system in our family uh and
she came out that trip and she was like
i didn't put my head up because of those
six-year-old girls that i didn't
remember
and so like again once you see it you
know
now she's got her own podcast and she's
putting her head up and so
i find i find that's a sweet story to
tell because it's not so
you know damningly personal but there's
so many
opportunities like that that i figured
you know it's time at least to
to broaden the conversation now listen
university of iowa to the teachers
college
might not have been the exact right
place but it was where i was invited to
speak so
i'd love to highlight two lines
from that speech and one is in the
middle of a paragraph so
i'll just highlight verbally one portion
of it really but it was
it's discussing your time at that
holistic health center in the desert of
arizona 28 day rehab center and it says
the 28 days didn't fix me or changed me
no it just gave me a start at
understanding who i was what forces
controlled me and then here's the part
that really jumped out of me what
stories in my life were so strong i
didn't even
realize they were stories right
so now i'm zooming out because many of
the stories we have our narratives about
ourselves and the world
may not be stories we're aware our
stories they're just
our reality and they're often stories
that
were given to us inadvertently or
purposefully
and we're not aware that we've absorbed
them so my question
relates to the next line and that is
coming back to the ayahuasca the lesson
i learned on my last ceremony
was that this medicine this process was
meeting me where i was and that was
gentleness you must start by being
gentle to yourself
so like you i think you've competed at a
much higher level in
many many arenas but i've always been
very very
very very competitive and uh
to the extent where being second place
has often for me been worse than being
15th place right it's kind of like
second place is first loser type
mentality
so i've been very mean to myself in the
same way this
those six-year-old girls were to your
sister right and so that
that has been kind of internalized and
i'd be curious to know what has helped
you to be
gentle or more gentle
with yourself gentler i guess would be
one of the two
you'd yeah you'd think as a writer i
would have this english figured out but
what has helped when a lot of people
would view
you know competitiveness as your
superpower right and it's such a driver
how have you
how have you learned to be better at
that well you know it's a work in
progress i remember before going down
there i
like i'm an easy going guy and i don't
lose my temper a lot so i think i'm a
nice boss
and i you know don't yell at people that
often and um
and i told my uh
lawyer who's been with me for 10 years i
said of course i'm an easy boss
and she's like dude you're absolutely
not a [ __ ] easy boss you're such a
tough boss
she said you're nice but you're tough
and i was like what do you mean she said
you never give a compliment
you're like oh that's pretty good butts
we're having the best party
like ah but if we only and they're like
you know how this disheartening that is
i was like oh made me feel
terrible and it was when i was on that
ayahuasca thing i realized
you can't be nice to people until you're
nice to yourself and i'm i never thought
i was tough on myself
why because i let myself get away with
you know the stuff that sent me to rehab
or drinking your drugs or
you know breaking the rules i've been a
rule breaking my whole life and so i
thought that's
well if you could do that you're not
really being tough on yourself uh
those are two different subject matters
i did the rest of that stuff because i
was so tough on myself and that was the
interesting part
i was like oh you should have only
and that internal angst i think
some of it was just getting older and i
think with success
there's a little less pressure and some
of it is now just trying to have
awareness of it and say it's not that
important
but you know i i think i pulled my
employees they'd say you changed little
but not a lot yet
and so you know it's certainly a work in
progress
i do notice it with my father you know
my father
was this great looking guy football star
spent his time in the army always was
nice to people
uh went to vietnam twice and in lots of
ways
she you know became a colonel but didn't
make general
and i remember when he didn't make
general it was painful in our family
because of course you want your dad to
succeed and
in the military it's like not making
partner goldman sachs there's a
hierarchy and you either get it or you
don't and
and it was painful for my parents for my
mother
who had done all the things and there
was some scandal behind it and there's
always some
back story um but i remember thinking
20 years later like looking at my father
at 70. now he's
83 and thinking do you think he gives a
rat's
ass that he didn't make general anymore
like his priorities had shifted he was
so happy to be around his family and
the work he was doing at this church and
and how we were all doing that
that ego piece he just let it go and
you know it i it didn't act like he let
it go he let it go
and so i think there's something about
aging gracefully
where you let that [ __ ] go because it
just doesn't really matter nearly as
much as you think it does at the time
and i think seeing that has helped you
know act like dad don't act like a
jackass that's kind of my fee
my my uh internal koan
mantra uh but
for me listen it's a work in progress
like you it's kind of built into the dna
of like
wanting to do things right when i throw
a party i want it to be a great party
and you know my poor my poor assistants
once bought a tent that was too big
and i literally thought i was gonna like
it it was like i died a thousand deaths
i saw this tent
i knew we had 200 people coming to the
party we had a tent big enough for 300
and all the energy would be diffuse have
fun in the big 10 jackass
but i'm trying to learn that it's but
it's
that's a process what advice do you
think
your older self 10 20 years older would
give to your current self
you know to to say you're you're you're
okay
like it's you're doing fine you're doing
great yes i have a shrink my my wife
calls him the greatest enabler of all
time
his whole mission is to say that's great
i'll like
make some confession he's like that's
great
and i was like well i'm not gonna get in
trouble uh
that's just to accept yourself i have a
funny story
there's a a friend he's he's become
he's not really a friend of mine i've
only met him three times but i had a
great time with him every time i met him
but he's a dear friend of paul jones a
guy by the name of peter goskey
and pete has a famous business where he
was like a posture expert
and then it was movement and he had come
back from
a vietnam war and healed himself and
then he's literally healed
thousands and thousands of people
celebrities athletes
the egoscue method it's called and when
you meet him you go through his process
he gives you a menu of exercises
how to get your back and his his
philosophy is if your body's in
alignment you'll be in alignment your
your emotions will be in alignment
and so i went to meet him the first time
it was supposed to be an hour meeting
and we spent like three hours talking
and i'm waiting for my menu what's my
menu by menu
at the very end he said no no no you
need to strip down naked stand in front
of your mirror every day for 15 minutes
and just accept yourself
i was like well that's that's my [ __ ]
menu so i remember getting
getting back and calling paul jones and
he laughed hysterically you didn't even
get a menu
you know
and so i think that's my 20 years from
now hopefully my
telling just accept yourself and that
was a little bit
that was a little bit the tattoo i was
like i am a [ __ ] puma and so put it
on your arm and remember like that's
part of who you are
so i have to ask did you try the 15
minutes for the mirror
i did it twice and i got embarrassed by
my body type
i literally didn't have the patience i
did try it a few times
but i didn't i didn't i didn't follow
through like he needed me to
well a work in progress as we all are
like you said let's chat about
criminal justice reform i know this is
incredibly important to you
i don't know the genesis story i don't
know how this
became important to you so i'd love to
hear you describe how that came to be
you know it's funny you know i guess if
i'm metaphysical about it
i i go back and i think well my my
parents
talking i remember my mother my mother
bringing me to head start when i was
four or five years old and
this idea of philanthropy being part of
our family but the more practical side
was
i saw brian stevenson speak once and was
wildly impressed at ted he gave us
kind of seminal speech and so that was
in the back of my head
and then my daughter anna got a job at i
think called the bronx defenders
where she was a 20 year old summer
intern
and she was trouncing around the bronx
collecting evidence for her lawyer's
cases and i'm like
you're actually the evidence collector
like how do you know like she's getting
you know video from bodegas and i'm like
you're you're the defense team
and i was like and so i was a impressed
with the work she did
and i was like wow that's what public
defense is
uh and you know i had made this
movie with nate parker when i say made i
didn't do anything other than invest
nate parker was a good friend of mine he
was a wrestler
and he had this dream of making this
movie called birth of a nation
and literally after 15 jack daniels uh
he convinced me to invest because i
really didn't want to invest in a
independent movie uh just thinking i'd
lose all my money
but nate was very persuasive and he's a
winner and so i bet on
and it won every award at sundance and
it's sold for
more money than any independent film
ever to this day
still right we sold for 18 million
dollars an independent movie
and you know it's a painful and
beautiful movie
uh but there's a big lynching scene in
it and
i saw brian stevenson who was building a
lynching museum
and so i said geez i'm going to take my
prophets or some of my prophets and give
them to brian
and but i said brian you got to come and
have breakfast at my house
and so he came and of course my daughter
hijacked the breakfast but we
we had breakfast and and really heard
his story
uh personally and asked a bunch of
questions the criminal justice system
and i just started getting angry
and then there was a thing called
audacious
you know the year cryptocurrency went
much higher
uh i made a whole lot of money on this
thing called ethereum
and you know to some of you it felt like
wampum be about wampa went way up in
price and i sold it and
and it was a you know kind of a
breathtaking amount of money and
i wanted to do something fun for myself
and i wanted to
so i didn't feel so guilty and because i
kind of thought it would have been
karmic justice give it equal amount to
something else so i bought a g550
i never had a jet uh which was which was
extreme
uh but i decided to take this similar
amount of money in
and i heard this story about cash bail
unaffordable cash bail
that robin steinberg told and it's a
really simple story there are half a
million people that go to bed
every night in jail cell solely because
they can't afford to pay bail
and you know the average bail we pay is
somewhere
close to eighteen hundred dollars most
people in america
don't have five hundred dollars most
people are getting arrested don't have
access to five hundred dollars so they
stay in jail
they're seven times more likely to plead
guilty if they're in jail than if
they're not in jail
when we bail them out fifty percent of
the time the d.a drops the charges
when you're in jail 40 of all prison
death and prison rape happens in the
first
you know 14 days you're there and it has
horrific long-term consequences for the
person and the
and the city and it just felt so
stupidly unjust
that i impulsively said i will donate a
bunch of money and share this thing the
bail project
and then i woke up and i was like well
the veil project is going to be the
biggest bail fund by a factor of
30 or more in the country you better
understand the criminal justice
landscape
and so i hired a guy billy waterson
who's been an a plus
and a small team and we started mapping
out
having activists come in formerly
incarcerated people come in
visiting prisons and jails and
with every rock we looked under you just
get more and more pissed off
you get infuriated it is a system of
stupidity it is a system of spite and
meanness
there is nothing rehabilitated at all
it's racially oppressive
it's literally like let's figure out how
we can strip people their dignity
uh oh let's make them [ __ ] in public
that's a very
nice you know it's like it's the whole
system is just
bizarre and it doesn't have to be that
way we participate on a trip where you
took
35 people to norway and into germany
and you look at the german prisons and
you would give them a 95 out of 100
and you'd give norway 99 out of 100 and
we're not a 60 out of 100 we're like a
14.
like we're that bad and so it just got
me angry
you know fairness had always been a
thing in my life i think growing up
middle class you thought it was not fair
that rich kids had a you know better
start than i did
and you know you talk about not fair
middle class to to rich kids the the
prison system is just
absolutely unfair and it you know it it
preys on
uh communities that are already in
duress you know
i think about women in prison how about
this statistic 95
of women in prison have been raped so
we're taking people
that have been traumatized and putting
him into a trauma machine
like who in the [ __ ] thinks that's a
good idea uh
and so anyway i i get angry thinking
about it but so we've
we've gotten involved i think we're you
know i'm on
the board of this thing called the
reform alliance which has been fun
uh because we're doing great work around
probation and parole and
you know that's jay-z and meek mill and
robert kraft and
we have you know participated and funded
or partially funded probably 15
20 different organizations and really
it's been a big part of my life
i still am a novice to be fair i'm less
than three years in and so
i'm a good enough storyteller that i can
tell the story
other people's stories and hear them but
we need a complete overhaul
and the only optimism i see is that you
know when i started even there was like
only a hundred million dollars of
philanthropy coming into the space and
four years later there's
600 million dollars or more uh it feels
like
the ball's starting to roll downhill
this covet thing is really
shine the light on just how horribly we
treat the
the most vulnerable people i would tell
you it's interesting
i looked before i came on there are 15
countries that have decarcerated by 18
italy iran of all places france right
they're like okay
shouldn't keep people in prison when
they're gonna die because of this damn
virus the us is about two and a half
percent
and so well that's a lot of people right
and they've all come out of jails not
prisons
so for you those who don't know jail is
one year and under
and often pre-trial and prison is one
year
and longer and so we just haven't gotten
around to saying
yeah we need to fix this and we're way
off our sentences are three times longer
than germany's for this same crime
just mean
and for people who would like to learn
more about this are there any
starting points you would recommend sure
ted talk
or a website or anything else you know
brian stevenson's ted talk
is spectacular because it really gives a
framework of
where this all started right it started
with slavery and we've never really
dealt with the trauma of slavery
robin steinberg gave a ted talk that's
fantastic about
and the bail project uh and philip gough
philip adeba goff did one about policing
and so like we're we're not anti-police
to be fair we're like okay how do you
help
the police department actually you know
have have data so they can you know be
fair in how they police
and so you know that's a controversial
one because people like oscar the police
they're they're
you know you can't you got to have
people all engaged all parties have to
be engaged and trying to say hey we need
to make a better system
and i do feel some optimism i mean even
trump as much as i dislike trump and
would love him at a cage match uh you
know criminal justice because
jared kushner's father spent time in
jail
criminal justice is one of the few
things that the trump administration has
been okay on
not great but certainly okay the first
step back was a great start
you know and they they've been helpful
and so
but again to put in perspective we have
2.3 million people in jail or prison
and having done a whole lot of analysis
on this
i think that should be 800 000 and
that's a little big difference we have
five million people that go to prison
every year it's like a
jail every year it's like a revolving
door they stay in an average of 45 days
two and a half million of them are going
there just for violating parole
which is bizarre we should have nobody
on parole and so we have
we have a long way to go and i fear you
pass one or two acts and you declare
victory and the numbers never change and
so
we're working on trying to get like a
scoreboard so the whole country can say
all right
this is where we think we need to get
have people agree to it and then
work to get there i want to shift gears
just a little bit
to a few questions i like to ask a lot
of my guests
and if if any of them are dead ends
we can we can scrap but i'm curious to
know
what if any are books that you've given
as
often as gifts to other people there's
one book that i've given
40 copies away probably and it's called
reminiscence of a stock operator
and for anyone who wants to be a traitor
or an investor
this is the bible it was written in 1932
by a guy who was at that time maybe the
world's greatest speculator
jesse livermore is the fictional
character
and what's crazy about it is you can
read it today in 2020
and it literally is still the bible and
so every great trader
annotates it tears pages out of it
it used to be a tell when people would
come to interview to to work and this i
really
all i care about is trading i was like
well tell me two books you've read about
trading
oh i haven't read any books and i was
like okay here's a book go read it and
come back when you've read it
but you're not getting a job you know
because you lied because you lied to me
because you really didn't care that much
about trading
if you've never read a book on it but
that's that's the book
and you know there's i there's a you
know anecdote
afterward to it is that you know two
years after he wrote the book the guy
committed suicide because he just
couldn't take the uh
he lost his fortune yet again but he put
every rule that you need to you know the
disciplined side of it
is all in that book and so it's and it's
a quick read you can read in three hours
i want to ask about because you
mentioned earlier that you run into
certain people who seem to have
a finely honed true north that they've
had
since age eight right someone like your
sister
uh or some of the names that you
mentioned
when you feel unfocused
or overwhelmed scattered fill in your
adjective
even temporarily what do you do you
personally
if you're feeling like you've committed
to too many things or just not sure
how focused your energies are is there
anything you do to refocus
yeah i think say no for me saying that
was like been the hardest thing you
didn't want to disappoint people it's
comes from my mother wanted me to be a
senator uh
and so learning how to say no and and
draw a boundary
has been really important to me and it's
hard for me i
call back three phone calls and finally
say no
and so by cutting a couple things out
i think helps me and actually the other
thing is writing it all on a
on a whiteboard so it takes it out of my
stress zone
in onto the whiteboard and i'm like okay
i see it all
it might be a [ __ ] load of stuff but at
least it's up there on the board and i
can put boxes around it i can start
attacking it
and so i think that's probably the most
powerful is literally getting it all out
of my head
and putting it and i'm a very visual
person so like
it's different to do for me like a white
board or a big piece of paper is
different than writing notes uh because
i put little boxes and i say okay
here's my criminal justice stuff i want
to work on here's my
and like what are the stress points yeah
doug mcmillan of
walmart uses a whiteboard very similarly
i need to get a whiteboard
i think what this is saying to me other
than my
like envelopes and uh diary of a madman
scraps of paper i think i need something
yeah
a lot of my a lot of my whiteboards are
metaphoric they're
the back of the back of a piece of paper
but they function the same way
do you have any quotes that you live
your life by or think of often i mean
are
there any any that come to mind for you
one of my favorite quotes is from saint
augustine it's lord give me chastity
incontinence
but not just yet
[Music]
i you know i remember leaving rehab and
that was my joke
yeah yeah yeah we heard a big circle and
everyone's you know banging the floor
and you had to give a story and i was
like what
like part of that is that tension always
between
doing what you're supposed to do and you
know you're supposed to do and what you
want to do
and so i do think i i laugh at that
quote but i do hold that
tension and you know in my hands
part of being alive is being impulsive
and breaking like
you know i i take take personality tests
and i just
i'm 37 out of 40 as a rule breaker and
so sorry i have a son that will break a
rule just keep off the grass
he keeps off the grass he doesn't drink
because he's not old enough to drink
you know every high school kid drinks
other than my one son
nacho who's the sweetest kid around and
i was thinking to himself it's just
different brain chemistry
because it's just part of it's it's it's
nature and nurture but part of it's
nurturing but
so much but i think is also brain
chemistry because like you know his
brothers and sisters like the
the we have a whole family of social and
yeah the way to pressure the guy to
drink a little bit here and there but uh
he's like no and i'm so impressed at how
confident he is with his ability to put
up boundaries and just say no
and then be like dad you're going 90
miles an hour you speed them at 60.
like oops sorry and so
for me that quote's important because it
holds those things in tension
just a few more questions uh this is one
on on investing but it's a little
broader than financial instruments it
could be but what is the best or most
worthwhile
personal investment you've made or just
one of your your better investments that
could be an investment of money time
energy or other resources does anything
come to mind it could be a trade
you know unless i you know cheeky i
bought a theory when it was one and it
went to 1300
you know like i bought a jet like in
lots of other things
uh but i don't think that really i
because that kind of felt a little bit
lucky and i was already rich
i actually think investing in
friendships you know i
partly i'm a hyper-social guy uh and so
it came
natural to me but when i think about my
life and what gives it joy
it is these circles of friendships i
have
my highlight to my life is this party i
throw every two to four years
depending on how i'm financially doing
where
300 odd people 350 people from my
universe
get together and we play sports and
listen to music and drink too much and
and it's a three-day event that takes a
huge amount of effort to put on
but i feel like most complete in some
ways like this is my
exclamation point on the world on how i
want to live uh and so
for me it's friendships you know their
high school friendships college
friendships work friendships
friendships people i meet at conferences
and they're not all
and they need to be invested otherwise
if you don't have new shared experiences
they're just they they go kind of go
away yeah well it comes back to it you
mentioned
earlier in a way which was the advice
you received of looking at who's at your
funeral right and worrying about
those people and no one else well mike
this has been extremely fun
is there anything else you'd like to add
anything else you'd like to discuss or
mention before we wrap up
i think you you covered a broad range in
my life i
don't want to bore you your your
listeners uh i think that was great
i think that was great uh i you know i
remember meeting you
freaking uh probably 12 13 years ago
uh when you're an up-and-comer and it's
been awesome and just because you went
to princeton and you wrestled and i
have it took a special interest but i've
been amazed at
you know the following you've built the
adventures you've been on
i still go back to the i was telling you
this
your first book uh the testosterone
chapter and the
and the orgasm chapter are required
reading i think for everybody
and so i you know just proud you know
proud to be your friend and uh
love that i gotta get on your show and
congrats on all the success
oh thanks so much mike uh you know the
four hour body the chapters
with so many vagina illustrations that i
got yanked from costco that's my claim
to fame
and it's been nice to get to know you
and adults should give all their teenage
boys that chapter and they will have
happier boys and happier girlfriends
[Laughter]
well mike thank you again for taking the
time
and to everybody listening you can find
mike
on twitter at novogratz you can learn
more about galaxy digital galaxy digital
dot io i'll put links to everything in
the show notes all the books ted talks
organizations that we've discussed
and until next time thanks for listening
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and
five bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things
i've found or that i've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that i've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just
a little tiny bite of goodness before
you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
element spelled lmnt what on earth is
element it is a delicious sugar-free
electrolyte drink mix
i've stocked up on boxes and boxes of
this it was one of the first things that
i bought
when i saw copic coming down the pike
and i usually use one to two per day
element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto low carb or paleo diet or if you
drink a ton of water and you might not
have the right balance
that's often when i drink it or if
you're doing any type of endurance
exercise
mountain biking etc another application
if you've ever struggled to feel good
on keto low carb or paleo it's most
likely because
even if you're consciously consuming
electrolytes you're just not getting
enough
and it relates to a bunch of stuff like
a hormone called aldosterone blah blah
blah when insulin is low but suffice to
say
this is where element again spelled lmnt
can help my favorite flavor by far is
citrus
salt which is a side note you can also
use to make a kick-ass
no-sugar margarita but for special
occasions obviously
you're probably already familiar with
one of the names behind it
rob wolff r-o-b-b rob wolf who is a
former research biochemist
and two-time new york times best-selling
author of the paleo solution and wired
to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch
that's how it got started his brazilian
jiu jitsu coaches turned him on to
electrolytes
as a performance enhancer things clicked
and bam
company was born so if you're on a low
carb diet or
fasting electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness
and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be
by one of my favorite athlete friends
three navy seal teams as prescribed by
their master chief
marine units fbi sniper teams at least
five nfl teams who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on and on
you can try it risk free
if you don't like it element will give
you your money back no questions asked
they have extremely low return rates
so again element lmnt came up with a
very special offer for you guys
they've created tim's club just go to
drinkelement.com
tim select subscribe and save and use
promo code tim's club
to get the 30 count box of element for
only 36
this will be valid for the lifetime of
the subscription and you can pause at
any time
so again check it out it's drink
lmnt.com
tim for this exclusive offer using promo
code tim's club one more time
drink lmnt element so drink
lmnt.com tim and promo code tim's club
check it out
this episode is brought to you by
pornhub
just kidding this episode is brought to
you by four sigmatic which
is part of my morning routine also part
of my afternoon
routine routine saves me so there are
a number of ways that i use for sigmatic
in the mornings i regularly start
with their mushroom coffee instead of
regular coffee
and it doesn't taste like mushroom let
me explain this first of all
zero sugar zero calories half the
caffeine of regular coffee
it's easy on my stomach tastes amazing
and all you have to do
is add hot water i use travel packets
i've been to probably a dozen countries
with various products from four sigmatic
and their mushroom coffee is top of the
list
that's number one i travel with it i
recommend it i give it to my employees
i give it to house guests so if you're
one of the sixty percent of americans or
more who drink coffee daily
consider switching it up this stuff is
amazing that's part one
that is the cognitive enhancement side
easy on the system side energizing side
the next is actually their chaga tea
which tastes delicious it is
decaf completely decaf and some may
recognize chaga it is nicknamed the king
of the mushrooms it is excellent for
immune system support so needless to say
i'm focused on that right now myself and
so i will often have that
in the afternoons they make all sorts of
different mushroom blends
if you are doing exercise as i am on a
daily basis to keep myself sane
cordyceps excellent for endurance they
have a whole slew of options that you
can check out
every single batch is third-party lab
tested for heavy metals allergens all
the bad stuff
to make sure that what gets into your
hands is what you want to put in your
mouth and they always offer a 100
money back guarantee so you can try it
risk free why not
i've worked out an exclusive offer with
four sigmatic on their best-selling
lion's mane coffee i literally have a
mug full of it in front of me right now
and this is just for you my dear podcast
listeners receive up to 39
off i don't know how we arrived at 39
but 39
off it's a lot they're best selling
lions main coffee bundles to claim this
deal you must go to 4sigmatic.com
tim this offer is only for you and is
not available on their regular website
go to four sigmatic that's
f-o-u-r-s-i-g-m-a-t-i-c
dot com tim to get yourself some awesome
and delicious
mushroom coffee full discount is applied
at checkout